hi I'm Max Keiser this is the kind of
report yeah where boy Nazaire is
Argentina so many hidden assets and
obvious assets this country freaking
rocks Stacey yes we're going to talk
about some of the opportunities that
have been taken over the last a few
months or years and you know it fits
into this theme that we've covered over
the past few years which is that as soon
as the u.s. used the US dollar and in
particular the Swift as a financial
weapon alternatives emerged and thus
said in the end of the power of empire
this has happened throughout history
hubris often sinks an empire when they
become a bully and so we're gonna look
at what a story about China China
working with a Dutch company by the way
here this is when the US slapped all
those tariffs on agricultural Goods and
all sorts of goods that China retaliated
by stopping all import Sasori being
products and of course Argentina is a
big producer of that so they're china's
pivoting and having to redevelop and
build infrastructure and countries that
they want to do business with so here's
a headline china wants to build a grains
super highway in argentina here is the
Parana River is their main waterway and
it dumps out into the ocean and here's
Uruguay here's Argentina
here's Buenos Aires and China has
stepped away from us agricultural
imports and said it would bid on a
project that could create a greens
superhighway in Argentina reported
Reuters Chinese state-owned construction
company CC CC is readying a bid that
would allow it to dredge Argentina's
Parana River the country's only river
that acts as a waterway for bulk vessels
that transport soybean and corn from the
Pampas farm belt to the South Atlantic
you know if David Ricardo who's the
contemporary of Adam Smith's talked
about comparative advantage and here a
comparative advantage speaking you've
got this huge river which would run
through the grain belt and give
Argentina a way to transport grain and
give them a leg up over Brazil and the
u.s. that has to spend a lot of money
moving the grain in the agriculture to
a rail track or whatever and so this is
a member could be a game changer
the British had the Industrial
Revolution due to the canal system they
gave them the ability to move stuff
around inter inter England waterways so
this could be a huge game changer and
it's just like the asset is there China
sees the asset they're gonna monetize
the asset they're stepping away from the
u.s. the u.s. and America are in this
the US and China are in a trade war and
so China is like okay we don't we don't
need to look that way we can go to
Argentina you know we can we can do the
New Silk Road with Russia so the u.s. is
not thinking it's not unique to the US
and it looks like we might pick on the
US but the fact is every single empire
has made the same exact mistakes for the
same exact reasons they become bullies
they become hubristic and they're used
to getting their way and they don't like
disobedience and the further away from
the Empire you are from the center the
more disobedience they tend to be and
then it costs a lot of money to send
resources there and an Armed Forces and
I think we have a big military base just
over the border in Paraguay you know it
takes it costs a lot and it costs a lot
to control to keep them from making
their own deals like China also for its
own part obviously it is a rising power
and we're not saying whether or not it's
a good power of bad power but what the
fact is that it is a power and it is
quite clever and it goes around it goes
to those edges of the Empire to do the
deals first because it doesn't want to
provoke the u.s. directly it's trying to
avoid that until the last possible
moment all markets create prices and all
prices are a signal that that signal is
either right or wrong and it doesn't
mean it's one political system or
another political system it's just a
number it's a signal generated by a
market and markets have always been with
us because people have always wanted a
trade from the beginning of people and
they always will want to trade the
nation-state is just a construct that
will came recently and will probably
disappear monarchies come and go but
trading has always been with us and
price signals have always been with us
all we do is tell you what the signals
tell the truth the signal is the truth
the price is the only truth in any news
you're ever going to read the price
is the only bit of truth that's it
everything else is conjecture by 2021
there will be a decision on this so it
right now is conjecture whether or not
China will get this deal to dredge the
Parana River or why would you name a
river Parana River trying to encourage
people to go bathe in the winter if it's
full of piranhas that sounds probable
I'm probably pronouncing it wrong and
all our Spanish viewers on Artie and
Espanola River they love provolone here
in Argentina nice fried provolone it's
fantastic no probe aletta probe alotta
you know 62% of the population of
Argentina is descended in some way from
Italians taste it you taste so fantastic
so marvelous just to point out again how
it will give it an advantage over the US
and Brazil the other two big
agricultural producers in this
hemisphere dredging Poorna
will give Argentina a significant
advantage over its competitors this
means farmers and Argentina's farm belts
can directly load their products onto
bulk carriers this is much different
from Brazil in the u.s. we have to
transport products by a truck or rail
over an extended distance to the nearest
port then of course the cheap peso is
great for exports and they receive a lot
of hard currency I US dollars from China
or UN who knows but another opportunity
here and this is an interesting one that
we've been covering in the US and that's
fracking and there's this huge reserves
found in Patagonia and total which is
the French company is the second largest
producer here but this is an interesting
data they have here total eyes shale oil
for growth in Argentina on concern of
low gas prices total the second largest
producer of natural gas and Argentina
plans to focus on its oil assets there
on concerns that an oversupply of gas
could drive prices to unprofitable
levels this is the Vaca Muerta shale
reserves in Patagonia and they said
there's huge potential to you know find
gas natural gas in these shale reserves
but the head of total in Argentina he
says we want to see at what level the
prices will stabilize we have seen in
the United States that gas can go to a
negative price we want to wait to see
what the price
gasps we'll be in Argentina because it
could fall to negative prices and that's
Dominique Mary on the shale catastrophe
in America and elsewhere has proven
itself to be a disaster and Argentina
could be dodging a bullet here because
all they have to do is look at what
happened to the US or in Great Britain
to understand that shell of course it's
negative prices it's always negative
prices because the amount of energy it
takes to do shale is greater than the
energy you get out it's negative energy
and it's also the amount of cash that
you need to do fracking is greater than
what you get out it's it's always cash
flow negative from day one its energy
negative from day one it's a negative it
don't Argentina don't do shell ok avoid
this catastrophe just forget about it
it's a loser it's dead on arrival forget
it don't do it
you can argue with them all you want but
the fact is they cannot print dollars
and you see that on the ground here that
is the problem they're having a currency
crisis because they cannot print dollars
America can print dollars so it could go
they could lose $30 on a unit of natural
gas in America and it doesn't matter
they could keep on producing this is the
raw information this is total saying
well in Argentina we actually have to
sell it we have to actually make a
profit so therefore natural gas is
unprofitable and it's a it's a weird
situation because here technology and
their work and our great technological
advances in the shale oil and natural
gas production it's been an amazing
technological advancement but it's a
standoff because it is so easy and they
are fast to ramp up compare it to
traditional oil and natural gas
production you're bringing up a good
point there is an interest it has to be
included in this understanding of shale
is that it's a money loser from day one
but it doesn't matter in the US because
all the creditors who lend money into
the shale industry are constantly being
bailed out by the central bank that
prints money that's why they do it for
the fees it's great for the banks but
it's not an energy play and it's not a
business it's it's a sinkhole but here
as you point out in Argentine
since they can't just print their way
out of a losing situation and the
economy is already a bit fragile you
don't want to add another loser into the
mix like shale drilling avoid it
completely this is part of that
situation of what price like there
there's plenty of natural gas and shale
oil and things like that but it would
but at what price not at the price that
people are willing to pay so therefore
we have a total gridlock around there
around the world I mean it's a weird
situation where the the price they can't
find an equilibrium because everybody
and their mom can start like drilling
very quickly as soon as the price goes
to a little bit profitable and then
everybody starts drilling for some
national gas and then the price
collapses again so it is very extremely
volatile another situation where we have
and this was an interesting story that I
saw this was from the summer and this is
Wolf Street calm and they were talking
about the airline situation here because
Matt green when he came into power he
deregulated the entire industry for
airlines and basically they found
themselves in a situation of offering
flights they're out there trying to
compete with each other because there
was just one national airline now
there's like six or seven here operating
and they're having to give away Fleiss
they're losing money on every seat but
hoping to make it up on volume the
airline Fiasco and Argentina as peso
collapse as a new plan goes awry on 27th
of December 2016 the federal government
Argentina under new president Mauricio
Macri launched the revolution they lost
a vionnet's that brainchild of the
minister transports a gear mow Dietrich
an ambitious plan aimed at overhauling
the stagnant airline industry in
Argentina while often called
deregulation it was actually a far
reaching an ambitious plan supported by
annual expenditures of about 1.5 billion
dollars by the federal government in the
airline sector over the 2017 to 2022
time frame including modernization of
many Argentine airports and construction
of the first Airport wholly dedicated to
low-cost airlines el Palomar near Buenos
Aires so it's been wildly successful
there's a huge like double-digit
increase in passenger numbers internally
but many of these airlines and we'll go
over some of the details in a bit but
they've been losing a massive amounts of
money well that's a typical transition
period all over the world countries go
from their national
Airlines to these you know highly
competitive cut-rate Airlines yes and
there's a lot of blood in the streets
that's called free-market capitalism I
mean there's nothing to worry about here
this is normal
that the entrepreneurs that started
these Airlines we're gonna go bankrupt
they love to go bankrupt they love
misery they love to fail because it's a
badge of honor let them fail they're
entrepreneurs let them fail that's
called free market capitalism and build
the build the airport's build the
runways build the infrastructure that's
your job
let the executives at the airlines and
the shareholders take the losses you
don't care about the shareholders they
take the risk they going to lose money
that's it that's why their shareholders
that's what that so that's what it's all
about part of the problem what has
happened is because the currency
collapse so fast all of their costs most
of their costs are in either US dollars
or Euros so you know the petrol for the
plane the the fuel for the plane the
training costs for the crew the leasing
of the plane which is the number one
cost so all of those their costs
suddenly doubled in the course of just a
few weeks they go bankrupt and all those
people are gonna have to get new jobs
but it's a very fluid economy and
there's a lot of different types of jobs
out there and this is the way it works
when you transition from a centrally
planned economy to a free-market economy
it's perfectly normal
embrace change embrace the chaos be the
chaos you want to be we're gonna take a
break when we come back much more coming
your way
welcome back to the kaisers report I'm
max geyser time now to turn to dr.
Frederico asked who's building the
justice system of the future he's also a
lecturer at Coursera singularity
University and others welcome thank you
once great to see you this is intriguing
stuff I can hardly wait to get into this
before we discuss the justice system of
the future that you were building let's
briefly discuss the situation in Buenos
Aires as an entrepreneur how difficult
does the frequent currency crisis make
for you or does it actually make it
easier to pitch Bitcoin or how does the
entrepreneur fit into the
entrepreneurial argentinian ecosystem
well actually Argentina had so many
problems in the past with currencies as
you know and bad governance that you
know building a company here is hard but
that's when you have cryptocurrency that
can help you to do something without
friction we can pay salaries with crypto
currencies you can like sell to the
abroad with repo currencies if you
wanted to do this with the traditional
banking and financial system would very
hard right because you have like capital
controls banks they don't give you the
money that detail you are paid so that's
why I think Argentina has such a big
community of developers for
cryptocurrency right so it seems to me
like the Argentinians have an extremely
agile mind because there's a lot of
emigration so there's a lot of languages
a lot of different ways of doing things
a lot of different backgrounds and it
all comes together in this melting pot
and people come together there's no
strong sense of community there's a
resiliency here and they've all they've
dealt with so many crises and it's kind
of like a startup failing again and
again and again but it makes as a badge
of honor really you know you've come
through the fire and you know you you're
in a good position I think that's why
Bitcoin adoption is skyrocketing
here in Argentina so let's talk about
the justice system of the future what is
it why is it how is it so we are living
in a world it's more globalized this
digitized so imagine you have contact
with some guy who is in another country
like purr for a website development
project and there's a dispute with a guy
so you're not going to another contract
to what Amala hug to court for like $100
or $1,000 so imagine if you could use a
system that is based on blockchain where
you send the money into an escrow and
then if there's a dispute with the
contractor then there is a jury that's
going to decide who is right they're
going to analyze the evidence like the
control do what you did and the product
that was delivered and they're going to
vote who is right and this is this
fall's a very important problem in
today's a globalized economy so the name
of this technology of this company is
klaris right and so these are smart
contracts smart contracts yeah
right and this is what we were told
etherium Excel that there's also
competition in that area from projects
like cordon oh and iOS and these are
smart contract type crypto blockchain
projects do you guys pick of those
enterprises of those of those cyst
projects which are better or do you are
you you know take any of them are any of
them doing better than others you know
so Clara's built on the theory room
because at this time we started it was
the largest crypto literally like the
smart contract platform but so potential
it can work in any other so because the
thing is that what we need for this to
work correctly is that there is
immutability in the in the agreements in
the contract so no one can tamper with
the jury selection and no one can tamper
with the evidence
so it's me theorem but could potentially
work in any other blocks right okay so
immutability is key and so these
contracts have global contracts is a
global world out there people are doing
business all over the world and it's to
have that kind of international exposure
is quite expensive for the average
person but with blockchain the cost
comes down incredibly down to almost a
gig economy levels of where people are
just putting up a few pesos really and
they can engineer a smart contracting
and launch a global business what give
us an example of how this is working so
for example this is working now at this
moment for token disputes you know you
know having exchanges that have to list
tokens and decide which tokens really
so this has traditionally been a very
like obscure process you never know how
the process works but so imagine having
a neutral jury decide which tokens it
should be accepted into an exchange like
and so this can have the possibility of
removing like lots of scams from the
crypto ecosystem so unless it's
something that is self regulated so this
is the community using the technology to
get rid of the scammers and to only
allow the legit tokens to to be listed
so this is a way of self-regulation
right is it going to jump out of the
crypto world into the other non crypto
world I mean you know you're talking
about juries and jury selection is is
something that is extremely arduous it's
it's time-consuming is there a way to
streamline that process and put on the
blockchain it'll speed up justice
absolutely um so there's not intended to
like replace traditional justice systems
which are like more complex it's not for
criminal but you know for kind of
commercial disputes and corporate kind
of dispute this can provide a much
faster and much simpler this bit
resolution process if you are running a
business in the mainstream world for
good crypto and you have lots of time
disputes and you don't want to go to
court for years like if you could have a
private arbitration system which already
exists but girls does it like 10x faster
and cheaper so that's that's what what
we're building right so typically in
businesses and startups there's a
there's always a lag time you know you
send out the invoice and then you know
you wait for the money to come in and a
lot of times businesses don't grow fast
enough and that they get behind and this
is a major problem and growing a
business so with a smart contract its
they're all synchronized right so the
payment and the delivery of the item or
the service is synchronized you get paid
with the delivery almost and it's all in
escrow and so you get rid of a major
deterrent for scaling a business which
would be accounts receivables totally
like imagine for example you are in the
US or whatever and you are thinking of
hiring some Argentinian developer so but
okay you don't know so if this if the
work he does is not good enough so I'm
not going to quote Argentina's complex
etc so
smart contracts give you like this type
of if you want rule of law as a service
that you get this the certainty that
okay if there is no compliance with the
rules of what was agreed so there is a
way to solve this so this is a very
important infrastructure for the world
economy right because usually people
when they get into business and they do
deals they have to decide a jurisdiction
yeah to resolve the differences there's
only GLE issues and it's your country or
my country here it's on the blockchain
and you already know ahead of time what
it's going to be the outcome and how are
you going to resolve these these
problems and so this is let me ask you
this the the many who are against the
REIT the major social media platforms
like Twitter or Facebook having power to
deep platform and silence voices I've
suggested a centralized decentralized
jury system to perform this function
okay so you have a situation now where
politicians have a lot of power for
example in America
there's this what's called the Russia
Gate hoax and they they buy into this
idea that there was interference even
though there's no evidence to that but
the major platforms like Twitter and
Facebook have been bullied to respond
can your product and your service
put that adjudication onto a blockchain
to try to make that fair and above
political kind of a foot as a political
football make it fair no it's a good
thing you mentioned is because Facebook
like what's Facebook now it's it's
become a tad virtual state in some way
right a state that creates rules and
that enforces rule they have like a army
of moderators who decide who is right
about like disputes happening there and
realize what information is going to be
shown or not so the fact that these
moderators are working a private setting
behind closed doors so you need some
kind of neutral like jewelry if you want
to decide and transparency and
transparent right because the blockchain
offers transparency exactly so right now
you just you just have a black box and
it's just Facebook makes a decision
somebody gets the platformed and they're
not sure exactly why and so this would
add transparency and
remove another layer to the look let me
ask you about Argentina some more
what what what arch what businesses are
needed on the ground from entrepreneurs
right now software technology like if
you could get one sector crypto
blockchain what what would really give
the entrepreneurs in Argentina a big
boost right now what are what's needed
I think what's needed is like like more
blockchain you know the country already
has this very big community people
working on building solutions for the
world because the good thing is building
a start-up in Argentina in the
blockchain industry enables you to do it
for the world before it used to be like
okay Europe's working Argentina okay you
do something for the regional market and
if you're lucky you get to Brazil now
you get projects like building things
for the world creating the future of
technology of civic technology right and
so I think that what's what's needed
here is like for first that government
doesn't interfere with this all this
like let the safe and they say pass a
house they used to say
and so entrepreneurs will find a way and
they will build stuff what's what is one
thing that people must understand about
Argentine businesspeople what do they
get wrong I don't know I think that one
thing of Argentina as you said in the
beginning so it's creativity is a child
of necessity and so people have become
very used to like be pivot all the time
like be creative and how to look for
solutions where there is seem not to be
any solution so you know I think that
the world is going to in the end like
see this super potential of this
creativity that we have here and so so I
think that that's undervalued for now
right so you have this pool of culture
and creativity and entrepreneurs and
they're in they're hardened
entrepreneurs because they've had to
live in a very volatile situation and
now they just need a path to a global
market and that path is being obstructed
by political machination certainly my
country America didn't help in 1976 you
know we there was a coup here we screwed
everything up
you know because America likes to make
everyone in debt they
to make everyone in debt and then they'd
like to steal stuff yeah so now a week
at a point where Argentina can escape
the American Empire of debt maybe with
cryptocurrency look at me
like I I am an employer here and they
had a chance to work with the team from
eight countries and create things for
the world this would have been
unthinkable like ten years ago
like before Satoshi Nakamoto was
impossible so now with the blockchain we
can access the world we can raise money
abroad we can go to customers in the
world we can pay salaries to every
country so it's this fringed
frictionless experience so enables lot
of this Argentinian creativity to become
yeah to go to the world house
well you mentioned Satoshi Nakamoto
there so this is Bitcoin so let me ask
you a Bitcoin question so there's a
Bitcoin and then there's all the other
alt coins and now we're at the pendulum
has swung back to Bitcoin maximalist and
do you feel that that's a valid
discussion to have in the Bitcoin
community because it there's so many
projects out there that are scams and by
focusing on this Bitcoin maximalism
maximalist it's a way to kind of weed
out and filter out all the noise and the
scams or do you feel that you know just
let the market decide I think that the
in the end is okay what problems can
block chain saw it right Bitcoin already
proved that can be a store of value so
scan smart contracts enable like rule of
law for the world for well a world where
rule of law doesn't depend on the
country where you were born or where you
work so I think the smart kid will sort
out what are the solutions that
blockchain can provide smart contract
and we'll see the 13 fair enough thanks
for being on the cars report I'm not
having me and that's gonna do it for
this edition of the kinds of report with
speedy Max Keiser and Stacia orbit like
to thank our guest
Frederico asked join a cat just on
Twitter it's guys report until next time
bye
you
[Music]